l'école reprend et plus que jamais les
enfants doivent veiller à leur hygiène
masque lavage des mains toutes les deux
heures jeux sans contact
le tout sous le strict contrôle des
enseignants alors bien que ce ne soit
pas le rôle habituel des professeurs
l'école a toujours tenté d'inculquer
certains bons gestes à des élèves
parfois un peu réticent former les
adultes de demain et si possible des
adultes propre voilà l'une des
préoccupations de l'école dans les
années 50 dans toute la france le
ministère de l'éducation organise des
concours d'hygiène en 1954 il s'agit
d'une dissertation sur l'eau et le savon
les dix lauréats ont été reçus par le
ministre ces jeunes auteurs qui ont
ainsi gagné une visite à versailles est
en voyage en belgique et en hollande
pays de la netteté ne se contente pas de
discourir sur la propreté il cela autre
concours en 1959 avec un cadeau de poids
faute de lingots d'or on remettait leur
poids de savon de toilette aux enfants
les plus propres de france vainqueur
parmi cinq cent mille écoliers du
concours national de la propreté
tout ça pour dire que d'hygiène des
enfants est une préoccupation nationale
à cette époque mais en pratique s'il ya
bien une partie du corps qui appelle la
vigilance ce sont les mains entre lancre
la terre les ballons de la récré avant
la cantine passage obligé par le robinet
sous l'oeil de cette enseigne en 1967
et après manger c'est au tour des dents
depuis les années soixante deux
dentistes viennent montrer aux enfants
comment éviter les caries avec
distribution de brosses à dents et
dentifrice et bien voyons le charbon est
ce qu'il ne te nettoie pas la peau et
bien le dentifrice et du savon pour les
dents tout simplement
mais les enfants restent des enfants
l'hygiène n'est pas leur priorité et ce
n'est pas l'état des locaux dans les
écoles qui va les aider
c'est ce que pointe le rapport d'un
docteur en 1978 illustration dans cette
école toilettes sales un bloc de papier
toilette pour 400 enfants deux
serviettes
depuis cette archive de 1978 les choses
n'ont pas beaucoup évolué selon un
sondage de 2018
seulement 10% des 10-14 ans se disaient
satisfaits de la propreté des toilettes
à l'école et 68% affirmé ne pas y aller
du tout
[Musique]